enseignants élus mobilisés ce matin
parmi les quatre écoles du quartier du
pré saint jean deux pourraient perdre
leur statut de rép
celle de saint-exupéry et cargo mare où
la mobilisation était la plus forte ce
matin et si on est quand même dans un
quartier assez particulier un peu
défavorisés il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui
ont besoin d'être soutenus scolairement
et que si on leur enlève ce statut ça va
être encore un grand gâchis et on veut
tous nos enfants réussissent mais aussi
les habitants se mobilisent également
pour les enfants du quartier
annie représente le conseil citoyen les
prés saint jean on dit il faut
absolument faire quelque chose pour les
quartiers il faut que le quartier
prennent une certaine dynamique et total
on s'aperçoit qu'on casse tout et qui ne
passera plus rien à quelques centaines
de mètres l'école anne-frank ce sont les
éternels oubliés
on comprend pas où est l'égalité il ya
que notre école qui a jamais été en rep
ou n'est pas classé en rép
donc voila nous souhaitons que ça bouge
que ça change
comble pour les parents d'élèves l'école
corto toute proche a intégré le
dispositif ferai pas la rentrée dernière
les élus demandent donc de la cohérence
dans les choix du rectorat
il faut que sur un même territoire ayant
les mêmes caractéristiques et vous voyez
que ces écoles sont très voisines sont
distantes de quelques mètres et bien
dizaine de mètres et bien il faut le
régime
retenu par le gouvernement de manière
égalitaire sur le territoire cet après
midi une intersyndicale avait lieu à
dijon avec le rectorat qui souhaitent
apaiser les inquiétudes
la cartographie des cachotteries coeur
d'être réponse est 'oui' à la rentrée et
donc des prochaine il y aura toutes les
réflexions et de l'identification hilal
est comme il est je suis de l'école je
ne doute pas qu'on aura encore onu
l'analyse de la situation avait quartier
pression comme le quartier du
département depuis la rentrée 2010 est
les écoles de kergomard et saint-exupéry
sont rattachés au collège camille
chevalier pour des raisons de mixité
sociale
cela pourrait changer en 2000
neuf à la faveur de la refondation de la
carte scolaire
[Musique]